[音楽]
始めたら大丈夫ですか
大ヤップラー油トレーナーああ今まつわる座れ
失礼します
昼食はい
1時間しか寝てねーんだいや
はいこれジャズ社長です
多分それだけでちょっとあの珍しく史上最強に睡眠不足状態なんですけれども
黒子党的なんだと思います神そのためでございます彼の僕仮眠が本当に得意なんですよ
10分寝るわーとか言ったら本当に10分に起きたに威力いるじゃないですか
仮眠するはつでそのまま終わってく人間のままもう寝ちゃって起きたらもうまぁこんな
時間なんじゃないか行くと思う
けど僕はもか皆レベル1ら違いすぎてちゃんと歓迎してちゃんと寝るんですけど何が音
とかに反応してちょっと大きくて立てば
例えばちゃんとあのすぐに体を起動できるでスッキリ爽やかんかはい
覚醒状態のの目指す意味をこうすぐスイッチできるみたいなべさすがに寝てるか出て
ないかなと動画じゃわかりづらいと思うんで
今回承認及びな作家音が僕が出てるか出てないかちょっと確認して皆さんに伝えて
もちろんでかよとスマ間違いで起きるんだなはいだから最初
レベル1とかちょっと分かりやすいユーザ振ったりいるがよ届かなくなってもらって
おっさいが本当にこれからで応募してたのをやめなかった今日
ただん
とかどんどんさんお気に隠していくんですけど私とあらばもう起きますから
わかりましたよろしくお願いですやいがーぴょんが早速髪にしますが本当にね
紙で大事なんですよでメートルと兼ねてを受けることスッキリするから僕はここ最近耳
につけた本当もう最強のスキルだと
入っていますどうだよ5分管理するこういうふうに大すぐにかしこまりました
ご覧ください
て込んないっ
[音楽]
goo
を
[音楽]
うんうん
ん
[音楽]
おはようございます
レベルは目覚まし時計ですアワーさせね受けさせておきますまあこれくらいは全然ね
ああ
[音楽]
全然を聞きますよねやっぱ寝不足だと思う奴らかもしれん
それを上回るのは本が好きですからねレベルミラーと the surf 後で応募し
てくれさい
[音楽]
を
うううう
goo
を
[音楽]
ウソでしょ知らせっ
おけますそれでもああああ落ち着きてきたや全然ですまぁ結果的にクリアすることです
ね
レベル ii 2回目だを目指してゆっくりと過ぎサンプルにしましょう
嬉しいです
くださいお待ちくださいいい
[音楽]
goo
はぁ
これはます
まあまあを供するキャッツと
機鋼の檻を出ましたねああああはい発動だけど
レベルグループましょう
え
読むんですか選んだてるよへい
ananan
[音楽]
を
俺ん
phase はいを経
はいお話
減給をやっほぉ
みつめがー
ないですかそれまだ全文できます次はちょっと眠りを深くしてみよ
7風まだわかりませんあなたグッズさらには八尾管理深いと食べなかなか起きにくいと
思う
そこでパッドを置きます8台
[音楽]
を
goo
[音楽]
大丈夫ですねはいはいはいはい動きました
起きたはいはーい
いやまだまだ行けますができますこっからどうするかだねそれを暗くしました
あーないんだけどねふうになりますこれぜます
はいおやすみぃ
[音楽]
p ん
ん
goo
源さんはいねー
うーん
ブーバーすっっ
yeah 普段
ちゃんだ起きるのはね僕も好きですからおやすみなさい
[音楽]
moon
分
[音楽]
とりあえずだったはっ最初ボスやばい何ひとも大きいれると思う
par
ん
あげたいよ
いや目にそれすらも覚えてないんだけど
違和感を感じたんだ何か買った事件結構がっつり寝た後に
を誰かに壁を盗んでしてもらいますこれで起きれたら僕はもほぼ最強の紙を今までとは
クラブ本で卵塊の二回か三問ているがしっかりとは起こさないけどもうと考えた場合
やろ
わかりました
[音楽]
ん
えっ
ああああっ
はいを決めましたあっはぁ
どうやって夫から
微妙に起きなかったですよね本当におぎやだった
今のって言って
ありー
やっていかが今っててい
えっなって今天ておきましょう
願ってくれ
[音楽]
me
うううう
ええええええ
あっはぁ